[Music]
now let's look at storage services that
AWS offers now storage makes up a very
big part of the services that AWS offers
in the cloud they are heavily used by
multiple organizations individuals
consumers around the world so let's go
and look at a few things so EBS is
essentially your block storage your hard
drives they are low latency and all of
your web servers and your database
servers your analytics engines they all
use EBS elastic block storage let's say
you have a requirement to have shared
file storage that is where you are going
to use elastic file storage and again it
provides high fault tolerance with
consistent latencies and you pay only
for what you use so you do not have to
pre provision it just in the case of EBS
you need to pre provision it then you
have s3 a simple storage service and one
of the most popular services of AWS
launched way back in 2006 it is secure
it has 11 9 steerability and it scales
past tens of trillions of objects and it
has many many use cases most importantly
for storage backup and recovery tiered
archiver we're going to look at a demo
of that thing and it also acts like a
data link for big data analytics now if
we have something called cold data that
we want to keep for our audit records or
some archival records AWS has something
called glacier that is very very
economical archival service the rates
start as low as like 4 cents a gigabyte
which is very very cheap you also have
something called Storage Gateway where
you apply this virtual device to your
data center and then you can store all
data through the storage gateway in the
cloud
is one of the very popular services in
the hybrid environment where you want to
keep some data in the cloud and some
data in your data center there are a
host of data transfer services which
help you move your data to cloud and it
can go from a small amount of data that
you can transfer over the Internet to
exabytes of data that you can transfer
through truck to a truck to AWS storage
services so you have something called
data connect where you connect directly
to AWS regional data transfer you bypass
the internet and then your network is
connected then you have something called
snowball which is like a box where you
migrate petabytes of data in batches to
the cloud then you have something called
snowmobile where you migrate exabytes of
data in batches to the cloud and they
will simply send a truck to your data
center you plug it in the truck will
roll into AWS data center and then they
will put data anywhere you want so let's
also take a look at Kinesis firehose as
well so you have these Kinesis streams
and you have ingestion process streaming
data your IOT data your mobile data your
Twitter feed the clickstream data these
are the things you can use Kinesis to
store and process all of that data this
is where you would come in AWS services
AWS console to request snowball
these are all the things that AWS gives
you to transfer your data again your
data is secure it's encrypted it's
addressed in transit and you can access
it anywhere using the Internet let's
look at s3 in AWS management console s3
is a place which is used for data leaks
for any sort of data that you would want
to upload in a cloud I can very easily
go and I can create a bucket so let's
create a bucket bucket is where you are
going to store your data alright so I
have created albert simply learn lab
bucket and if I click on it I can do so
many things over here I can upload any
data that I want over here I can send
the permissions of who all can access
this data by default in AWS it's a
shared responsibility model so I can
upload the data and I can choose who can
access this data in s3 there are so many
things that I can do with this bucket
that is my folder in the cloud s3 that
is simple storage service I can enable
versioning so I can keep all the
versions of my objects over here I can
set up logging I can set up a static
website hosting we will have a demo for
the static website hosting as well but
we don't have to worry about this
killing the load balancing etc it just
scales automatically I did mention that
is a great tool for disaster recovery
and what you can do is you can set up
your backups your snapshots in s3 you
can put all your data in s3 you can
simply enable the cross region
replication so what happens is that
let's say you are in US East one or
Northern Virginia region and you want to
set the cross region replication to
Oregon or maybe somewhere in Europe you
can just come over here and you can
enable the cross region rep
occations so what happens is AWS will
automatically replicate your data from
one region to another of your choice you
decide where you want your data to be
replicated AWS will not do so on its own
there are so many types of things that
you can do you can tag everything you
can give permissions to all your people
there are so many types of permissions
that you can give there is an access
control list you can set up a bucket
policy it's also tightly integrated with
Identity and Access Management so you
can very easily command who is able to
access your bucket apart from that there
are some really interesting things there
is something called lifecycle now this
is a tiered storage so normally whenever
you get data typically that data is
going to be very hot so you would define
the data or classify the data as a hot
data warm data or cold depending on how
frequently it is accessed then you would
normally have a tiered storage so s3 has
four classes that's a standard storage
and infrequent access storage reduced
redundancy storage where you would put
normally reproducible data and archival
storage that is glacier so what you
normally do
whenever you get some data you would
keep it in a standard and you would know
over a period of time you would want to
move that into an infrequent storage
like over here so I will say that move
this data into infrequent storage which
offers the same security same durability
but it's a lot cheaper okay and then
after that I can also add a data that I
want to move into archive which is
glacier after some time so we can add it
to glacier after 60 days and if I just
click on next this is where I will see
it and then I can also delete that
object after whatever the amount of time
that I would want and I click on it you
see here that I have set up a transition
rule
that says that for the current version
of the object anything that I add to
this s3 bucket I want to transition all
those objects automatically to standard
infrequent access class
and then I will be charged lesser than
what I've been charged now and then I
also want to transition to Amazon
glacier that is my archival service
after 60 days I do not want to delete
them ever so these are the things that
you can do with the s3 you also have a
lot of analytics tools which allow you
to see who is accessing your data what
data you have who is adding a lot of
data and these are all available to you
at a very economical rate
all these services are tightly
integrated with each other so you can
plug them in with an ec2 instance or i.m
and you can get all the information at
your fingertips
so let's talk about static website
hosting on s3 and this is one of the
very very powerful features of s3 where
we can actually host a website and it's
static and some part dynamic as well so
you do not need a web server to host
your website I have this bucket over
here
AWS agile dot n I click on it and you
can see that I have a couple of HTML
pages error HTML and index.html and then
my code my HTML CSS files my image my
video files are inside the folder so I
come over here I click on the properties
and you can see that the bucket hosting
is enabled so if I click on it all I
need is two documents then whatever I
want inside my website if I simply click
on this thing this is what I get now
these are the things that I have inside
my website my folder and the beauty of
it is that you do not need any web
servers you do not need any load
balancer you don't need any firewalls
you can simply give this URL and then
you can map it to your DNS the domain
name service and then anybody will type
your website name or your blog name and
then they are going to land on this page
and it's scalable it is load balanced
and you can scale it to any number of
people you can have millions of hits
coming in and this is one of the very
very very popular services of s3
hey once you become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simply learn
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing quick here